doing it with like Cam and David by
myself you ever need help with that let
me let me know what do you mean help
with uh running the show or whatever
yeah yeah I mean if you don't like doing
that or hello
hello yeah I mean it's kind of a pain in
the ass sometimes but uh they got a guy
they got a door guy there have you done
that show yet yeah yeah I've done a
couple I like that room a lot yeah like
if they get the right uh like
advertising or whatever is that
on yeah sorry it's just my my
mic they get like I think they should
just be doing uh barking there because
it's just right in the heart of Austin
where they could get some [__] going
yeah I like that room a lot I like
barking though I did it for rosos and I
did it once for black rabbit because I
got on a show there and I was trying to
get another one and Joey's just trying
to be like do you uh do you think you
get a good audience if you bark cuz
that's that's the thing I think it's
like saved our show at Rosco when I ran
a show at rosos I did the Dallas
Invasion we probably had like 10 20
tickets but we bark like 30 minutes
earlier and Rosco is not even the best
place for foot traffic you know what I'm
saying like especially that street but
if you go one over it's not too bad we
barking on the street that Rosco is on
right next to the plan parented the one
on the other
side so like Rosco's here and then you
can go behind rosos and there's that
pizza
place yes or maybe it's fifth but yes
yeah isn't Rosco's on the Alley and then
be on yeah that's a good walking
neighborhood though yeah so we probably
got maybe like five six more people
maybe even 10 because of that yeah so
what are these people like what are
their Vibes like are they like bored out
of their minds and they're just like
going going out into the world just
waiting for someone to tell them what to
do a little bit some of these people
yeah some of these people honestly
they're just like I don't think I would
respect that audience but hey whatever
it takes right just to fill the seats
man yeah at this point yeah it wasn't a
bad show it was like 35 I was expecting
literally like 10 people cuz you know I
didn't bring anybody that can bring
people which you know I don't expect
them to do that but then
yeah oh [__] oh is this live okay okay
this is going word
word I are we going to watch the podcast
and talk about it is that make sure okay
okay that's fair
let me play around with these buttons oh
yeah the compressor and stuff over
yesterday we were talking all over each
other did you listen to it no what no
why would I do that you put the
compressor all the way to 10 see what
happens put it cuz it it's supposed to
just flatten the noise it's supposed to
flatten your voice so then it's not as
like
wide let's talk at the same time ready
one two three sh sh
it's not bad I mean we have very
different tones of voice I think it's
like it doesn't matter how it sounds
through these because that comes from
there something weird happens when you
put it through the computer so that's
figure out oh okay are they
listen that's yeah it's not bad that's
not
bad it's not uh I mean but you're not
we're not supposed to be talking over
each other like when there was five of
us yesterday yeah we're having like two
different conversations sometimes you
know I just don't know what the
compressor does I think it helps though
because sometimes it takes the the EQ
and it just flattens it like that yeah
it compresses the sound that's why
that's why it's called compress [__] it
all up yeah they do that in music uh
there's this term in the music industry
called that made it big where it was uh
like compressor Wars and when he
compressed the file there you can make
it louder without
actually uh peeking out or whatever so
then everybody was kind of doing it cuz
he created like this wall of sound like
that's what the Beatles were about and
like a lot of rock so a lot of music now
yeah yeah yeah they use a lot of
compression so many soundways in this
tight little area pretty much that it
becomes like a wall yes so then people
can crank it and then you get that kind
of feel and that was like a big I mean
information in to each song it's changed
from there and now it's like you know
R&B and and rap and they have their own
version of that but yeah it's not so the
Dallas invasion you uh had a show yeah
and you barked and uh lot of and made
the show a lot better yeah yeah yeah
yeah I think barking I mean you got to
be in the right place you know what I'm
saying like if there's foot traffic
parking's doable I think right now
there's a lot of interest in comedy in
Austin because there's so many shows
going on so people get acclimatized to
it sure no it's like live music now
where people are like oh I don't want to
see this comedy show I can walk 3 feet
down the street and there's another
totally different type of comedy show
and there's the weird ones like the shot
collar one we were talking about that
yesterday the dog yeah which is
just I get it but yeah I get it uh
that's like not respecting the comedian
enough like nobody does ever nobody
respects comedians only like maybe the
the few top ones most Comics are just
looked at as not like even like a
homeless musician I think gets more
respect than uh like an open micer in a
sense CU at least a homeless musician's
like no scales yeah they know cords
that's what I was thinking about is like
what do I know how to do like yeah I can
talk in front of an audience in a very
specific way but it's not really
transferable to anything else no like
you couldn't be on the E Evening News
doing you could maybe be the weather guy
but those guys are usually pretty peppy
could be like the you got be the ominous
the ominous weather guy it's going to
rain today I think it ruins me for most
jobs doing
comedy cuz now get those jobs anyways
though were you going were you going to
be able to get those jobs anyway you
can't take [__] yeah um that's my
thoughts well I could have if you
focused maybe if I worked like to
tortured myself and did it fulltime what
would you
do anything like any any job like that
I'm talking about I would you could you
could change who you are from an early
age yeah no that's very true yeah but uh
now we're ruined cuz we comedy and we
can't really function in an environment
of [__] yeah which is most jobs true
like I couldn't be corporate but I was
never going to be corporate you could
you could have you could have fit in
corporate I could see you in a suit I
mean i' tried just cuz I look like I
could doesn't mean I'd be good at it I'd
be like a [__] corporate
guy because I think you'd be upper manag
brain into two like fake and real I just
don't want to do that I mean I'm barely
keeping it together with this one
personality I don't want have two sure
yeah yeah yeah no that's true so you do
feel like your onstage uh Persona is
kind of in line with your offstage
you know what I'm saying I'm not saying
it's a persona but like yeah you try to
be authentically yourself more on stage
and stuff yeah okay but that's not
really what I'm talking
about I'm just talking about just like
in a corporate environment yeah you got
to have your corporate talk I guess in
comedy you're saying like like cuz I'm I
have two personalities I have one that's
on stage and then who I am more so I try
to bring my authentic self on stage
but uh I'm a lot I think I'm a lot
meaner on stage I don't I'm I'm more
like sad and nice offstage I would say
I'm not saying I'm like completely nice
but like I'm not as like the [__] you
kind of deal we're on stage JY about it
you're like um yeah like [__] you but
haa it's funny enough but off stage you
would never risk saying that yeah no I'm
not just trying to unless I knew the
person very well and like my boys and
then I'll be like yeah like I'm sure
I've said at least like once or twice
too a little bit I think it's cuz on
stage you have a merit to do crazy
things yes a license to kill you know
you yeah they're like hey I want to see
you do if you go up there and do normal
things that's offensive yes well the
certain crowds which I I like crowds
yeah yeah well there's some crowds that
love I call it uh pop comedy you get
what I mean like there's a lot of Pop
comics that they you know they don't
want swearing then that's like they want
to still see a show they just want to
see the best version of something boring
yes and even that pop comedy has an edge
but it's just a totally different Edge
uhhuh so it's like to them that's edgy
but then you take it to the other place
and they're like that's that's
familyfriendly jokes or whatever which
is cool it's cool doing both I prefer
the dark and dirty or whatever more like
after hours adult kind of [__] it's just
style I don't really
[Music]
um pick and choose I think like
different moods I'm down for both I'm
pretty 5050 I'm I get that yeah I'm I'm
I'm more just like thinking about who I
am as a person I think I'm a little more
prickly for like a pop comedy crowd
compared
to yeah I'd like to think I'm more salt
of the earth kind of deal where it's
like I rather do like Blue Collar Comedy
more so than like white collar yeah in
in my opinion but you know white callers
got money so I'll [__] I'll make them
laugh too you so have you ever done a
crowd of like super rich people or like
a condo show kind of private shows doing
some private corporate gigs and stuff uh
it doesn't even have to be rich people
but people just that are trying to act
like they're rich like business that's
even that's even worse actually cuz then
it's like they want that facade of like
you have to respect me really rich folks
actually are pretty good at taking some
[__] to a degree and then well people
that actually do something and like got
their riches by being a real person like
you know Richard Branson or something
sure yeah he'll take a joke but it's
like so weird to brush up against that
in comedy to see this like
inhuman business culture and how they're
are divorced from laughter it's like
almost impossible to make them laugh
because they are so weird and when they
do laugh they all have to be unique they
like sure I haven't heard that I kind of
get what you're saying yeah different I
think it's cuz they're all an Aderall
that's why but the Aderall is theer end
result of the original cause of why they
want to take it but adal like meth you
know Germans run meth like you're not
[__] I'm talking about like the Nazis
right now but it's like that's they're
not there's a reason why they choose to
take it cuz it's productive yeah cuz
they want to feel that way so just cuz
it's they're on that drug doesn't mean
that it's the Drug's fault it's like
still 100% culture a little bit the
culture that CHS that drug people on
meth don't laugh that's what I'm saying
the the humor the humor becomes too
logical and they're trying to figure out
the logic compared to being like this is
a joke this is supposed to be fun it's
almost like how I look at standup now
and I'm not on adal but like I'm more
like studying it more so than just you
know enjoying it kind of deal where then
it's like that takes all
the the the times I laugh at comedy it's
because I've had like a couple drinks in
me or something or I just smoke some
weed and I'm just I'm not hyperfocused
on it and I think Aderall and everybody
being on Aderall has made people
hyperfocused where then people are like
oh what does this joke mean in the in
the grand scheme of life and it's like
so they're more analytical yeah which is
good in a lot of ways ones and zeros cuz
that's what they get paid for they don't
care about being human cuz if they were
human they would kill themselves or at
least stop doing their job
yeah that there's like a a a subsection
of our society that's like so [__] up
like that and we uh we have to deal with
them I think you need them though you
need some of those idiots and they're
not even idiots like I'm more of the
idiot in a sense but like you need those
kind of people to get you know the there
I mean not to diminishing them but gears
in the machine to [__] move things
along why do we need people that are
like machines we have machines the good
thing people is their emotions and if
these people don't have any emotions
they're just like computers yeah we can
delete them but the machines need people
to fix them right yeah so get a human
yeah
that it's sort of computer I I'd love
for the machines to take over the
day-to-day stuff so that humans can
relax but I don't see that I was
thinking about this why don't we just
get computer or uh animals like dogs
like AI self-driving car is hard but
just a dog that's going to bark when it
sees danger so then you incorporate that
interesting into it so you don't have to
start from Square One sure and we can
blame the dogs for being bad drivers
instead of yes yeah Asians or we can uh
we can uh have them do deliveries they
love running true what doing Uber Eats
and stuff we should be using animals
more yeah that's not but people don't
like people think that's like slavery
too which is you know what I mean like
there's no winning with people
eventually they're going to say the
robots are SL like the dogs would get
hit by cars yeah a lot of them would die
yeah or I would probably just start
picking up dogs so I can get some free
food just being like here boy it's
[__] it's kind of like those uh I
forgot what those called the St Bernards
where they had the alcohol on their neck
you remember those in like cartoons and
then they would go in the snow the Red
Cross on it yeah yeah yeah Health
alcohol in that situation maybe it is
yeah
yeah if you were in a survival situation
would you be like let's get
drunk once the dog came yeah maybe to
relax cuz I'm assuming the dog's I'm
assuming the dog's going to be yeah
taken over you're in good spirits when
they rescue you so that you're not like
thrashing around what there's no better
way to get rescued than by like just a
dog with booze on maybe like a shot girl
maybe like a really hot girl for for
some reason that's you can't carry that
around a St Bernard though what a hot
girl no the I'm saying now replace the
dog with just the like the first thing
you want to see when you survive is
either like a dog or like a really hot
chick I think yeah right that would be
nice I'm thinking like back in the day
this was the thing that gave them the
most happiness per unit volume so
they're like let's load them up with
alcohol like we could give him cheese or
bread or that's true they should have
some food that's a good point or some
water yeah yeah right but that's not as
vable to them as alcohol is I would
prefer a dog with just a syringe and
heroin around his neck and then I'm like
oh I'm saved I'm saved yeah give them
the must bang for your buck yeah little
fentanyl just skip it don't even have to
shoot it you just touch it on your
finger and you're dead absorb it yeah
yep like the cops do yeah yeah cops can
absorb fenel through their eyes just by
looking at it is that drun what yeah
they're uh always complaining about that
yeah they are no they are yeah yeah well
[__] you up they should just start
putting fentanyl in the water so
everybody gets a nice base coat so that
they don't so they develop a tolerance
yeah kind of like The Princess Bride
kind of stuff yeah they should put in
like snake venom throw that all develop
an immunity sure sure and then when a
foreigner comes they're just going to
get [__] up yeah no then and that
controls the illegal immigration yeah
cuz then you have water yeah yeah yeah
not because it it'll make you sick it'll
make you feel so good and then and then
you'll and then you'll die yeah from
feeling so good does my voice sound more
muted than
yours uh I think that's just a general
thing with you though you don't think
it's the a very mute kind of person well
I don't think mute I think it's just
more like not as
sharp um yeah you could change the eqs
on that if you
want which one's yours here listen the
one closer to me
two like more
highs um
yeah lows maybe a little less just make
it the same I don't want it to yeah that
sounds better I think yeah I can't hear
it but yeah sounds like a same voice so
uh what are you doing in uh in Austin
nowadays uh living out my car still I
mean couch surfing here and there and
then yeah
[__] uh are you
uh going to like see the sites are you
going to like Zilker Park and [__] no I
mean sometimes but that's because I got
nowhere else to go and I know Zilker
Park's a pretty s safe place in general
I mean I'm crashing at Like Comics
couches and stuff like it's not it's not
like I'm living on the the street but
you know I'm I'm figuring out and I have
some money saved up where I think yeah
probably in a month or two maybe
especially if I get that job at uh
Vulcan then I can save some more
probably get a place or crash with
Comics or something like that do you
like
Austin it's a it's a hate love thing man
it's a hate because I used to live here
before standup so like I was here in
like
200 8 to 2012 and a lot of that was with
the drug addiction [__] and stuff and
there this a good place for that drugs
yeah man yeah yeah was it better than
Dallas uh you know what the drugs were
different so like Dallas was more like
meth Coke and like ecstasy and then here
was like acid shrooms weed
and heroin's everywhere if you look for
it but yeah where did you start here
here pretty or kind of I kind of did a
little bit in Dallas but it was like
cheese you know what that is no it's
like it's heroin in Advil that drugg
dealers put or Tylenol Tylenol PM that
drug dealers make and it's kind of like
a light heroin pretty
much yeah and then when I came here uh I
was going through a breakup and just
[__] me up in the wrong way and just
started doing all sorts of different
drugs and then yeah kind of got a hold
of me got arrested to drug almost went
to prison went to a drug court and then
went back to Dallas and then came and
then started doing comedy in Dallas
after like 3 four years so you are out
of jail it's been three or four years
made you start
comedy uh man like I was kind of lost I
was in school for uh I was doing music I
was trying to cuz like I was down here
trying to be a musician too and I just I
think the reason why I didn't make it or
or try as music because I think with
music a lot of times it's like you got
to have a group and I'm not really good
in groups I'm kind of solo like I like
being part of a group but you're more of
like a tennis player and not really a
baseball player yeah yeah yeah yeah well
said and I can still play doubles so
it's not like I can't play well with
others but who do you like to play
doubles
with some of my Bo Tom Murphy you know
who Tom Murphy is is he redheaded yeah I
think I know yeah that's my boy yeah
yeah love him uh to death uh you like
voling with him yeah yeah he's a good
he's a good volley partner um there's
there's a there's a few you did music
and you're like I want to do something
artistic but not musical yeah and I
think also playing I like playing music
for myself it's not one of those things
I care to share about I don't mind doing
it you know but yeah it's personal yeah
more personal than that and comedy was
just uh perfect for me and then you know
Dallas scene blew up and then Austin
blew up and it was just it's weirdly
lucky that I'm here even though I'm in
my [__] car
yeah scene in Austin no just my career
or whatever you want to call it in
comedy like how what you've done so far
yeah yeah and I'm still haven't done
[__] but it's still like you know it's
just these weird little moments of luck
that I was like oh and then a whole new
door opened or something you know like
when like uh I got like banned for my
club and stuff and then that I ended up
helping me out I remember uh about to
move to LA and then covid happened so
that kind of prevented it and then Joe
Rogan moved here and I was like this is
way better than I feel like trying to
make it in LA or New York where I was
like this is there La in New York is
just so sad just like La is not bad i'
I've been out there it's not like
terrible uh well a lot of people hate it
I can imagine and uh it's over it's
almost saturated the fact that there's
only two cities is just not enough it's
like this is not mathematically going to
work out and the fact that everyone
thinks they have to go there it's just
like everything else with our culture
it's just like monoculture sure it's two
parties Marvel DC you don't feel that
way with Austin at all Austin is a new
thing it's still growing so it's not
saturated yet but obviously there needs
to be more than just Austin New York La
sure Chicago and I think it's better to
have a Richard more diversity and it
takes more brain power to be like oh
yeah Chicago's like that New York's like
this yeah but I think it makes it better
more deeper and richer and stronger yeah
yeah I mean Austin in a good spot too
because it does have Dallas it does have
San Antonio and it does have Houston
where it's like those aren't those
aren't close but they're you know I've
always thought about they're giant
Dallas and Houston are huge but Houston
doesn't have enough clubs they need to
open up for how big they are they have
like three four clubs you know they
should be like Dallas almost where it's
like and you know what I've always
thought uh I've always thought about
opening a club in Waco you know what I'm
talking about north north of here
um wakeo yes yeah cuz it's it's a
college town There's [__] nothing
there I think there's like one Comedy
Club there and it's like it's a blackbox
theater so it's not even fully comedy
and it's right smack dab in the middle
of Austin and Dallas and the amount of
people in both of those places it's just
uh ridiculous you know only problem is I
wouldn't want to start there like I
wouldn't want to grow Comics there I I
just feel like yeah I mean if you're
gonna own a comedy club you're going to
have to be there a lot Ino and it's like
it takes away from doing comedy I feel
like owning a comedy club yeah even
producing one you're just you know that
[__] that's a pain that me doing that
one Dallas Invasion show I was like [__]
this I mean I'll I'll do a couple of
them but yeah being a producer sucks I
have a lot of respect for I also do hate
producers but like I have a lot of
respect for what they do well you know
what I'm saying some people don't use
the power right because they didn't
really earn it exactly cuz they just
sort of got it however they got it sure
or you know they just right place right
time they're the ony yeah they were like
hey I'm going to ask this guy respect
that I respect the gumption but then
that's not enough no it doesn't make you
a better person or comic yeah it's not
hard enough yeah um but yes uh I think
that the best way to do it is the way
Joe Rogan did it obviously is where
you're so rich oh okay that you can just
buy a comedy club true and yeah just put
the money in it to run it right yeah and
you don't really have to like manage it
yeah I was going to do that too but then
I realized I didn't have any I didn't
have any money that was it was a big
Crux in the flaw there but you know get
a apartment before you get a comedy club
bro I would probably get a comedy club
before I get an apartment a little bit
if comedy wanted me to have an apartment
if comedy wanted me to have apartment I
would you could sleep in the comedy club
that's what I'm saying that's probably
what would happen man you know [__]
why why get an
apartment I if like I was getting
something it would probably be like a
house like I don't I've done the
apartment thing man it's just they take
your security deposit every single time
you know I don't know I want like
temporary housing that's what I want
where I can move around so uh you did
Dallas comedy for how many years eight
2015 it was killing it at the uh hyena
show Dallas and Fort Worth actually uh I
saw on Reddit when you know when I was
taking pictures of you guys sometimes
I'll take a picture of myself just you
know what I'm saying and then uh I saw
in RIT somebody making fun of me for
that no yeah he said I sucked and I was
like I thought I did pretty
good damn yeah yeah that was great no
those were great shows great I think uh
your jokes are so funny I was laughing
thanks man
I like it because you try to do
something emotionally interesting to the
audience you don't just try to be like
and then that my dog went up the stairs
uhuh sure sure you're like hey uh is
there kind of [__] up
pedophiles uh look like me I didn't say
that but sure I don't know I think
you're making your own it seems pretty
hard to make an example of that or just
like it's you just like to [__] with
them a little bit in a playful way which
is like I like that I like com with
teeth I don't like people that just want
to like gently pet the audience pop
comedy that's what [__] shove them a
little bit you know just like hey man
we're alive this is live like if you
wanted to just watch my [__] go watch it
on on the internet cuz then you have
that you're in the building and you're
being emotionally manipulated and people
like that they like to be jerked around
sometimes I'm sure sometimes they don't
kind of verbal BDSM you know what I'm
saying like yeah some people want to get
slapped around a little bit verbally
yeah it's terrible for my personal
relationships yeah I'm not doing heroin
anymore well I feel like that's like
part of your personality now probably
yeah and i' and part of the problem was
I made it that but then when I was
getting into comedy I was just getting
out of it so like it was and now like
eight years later it's like it's not me
but it's it still is you know like like
you and the van right that's probably
still a part of you right m no no I'm
way past that it's nice I don't even
think about that van anymore you don't
look at Vans now you're like damn dude
that's a [__] you can tell when
person has a good van yeah basic based
on the what's on top but uh okay yeah I
mean uh the van life was fun you know I
enjoyed doing it MH I uh you did as long
as I was doing like her was you doing it
for like 10 years lived in a van yeah
yeah or like you were how long were you
living in a van like four still pretty
long but yeah okay okay well I think it
was round four but I mean the van was
fun I loved doing it I loved like taking
back my time I don't want to give my
time so I can go to a guy and buy a
place to rent it's like I got to go
through like so many middlemen just to
get a place to live like I'll just make
my own place and that's saving so much
more time than if I worked for someone
else to buy a house or like a tiny home
yeah now I'm with you it's just more
efficient in my opinion and then I was
just doing mics in New York all the time
which I need to do more of I need to
like hit go to shitty mics so that I
understand a skeptical crowd yeah
listening to me or even almost a hostile
crowd cuz undeniably funny so that they
have to laugh I think that will help me
yeah kind of uh you know steel Sharp and
steel [__] where it's like if they don't
want to laugh and then you still make
them laugh I think a lot of uh people
that uh do open mics like to like think
that it's more important than it is I
don't think it's like the most important
thing no but I think it is good for uh
honing bits and it depends on the mic
too cuz some mics are just not worth it
at all that's true the one that we I
don't think that was problem so it's
like in that yeah I was like [__] dude
yeah [__] that
Mike yeah uh lake lake no don't
say okay
the guy's a nice guy no I'm sure he is
dude yeah yeah well all of the mics can
go suck it after a certain point like
there's always going to be [__] mics but
yeah I think but with you you got so
many eyeballs a lot of times on you
going to those mics you can kind of go
back to just being anonymous yeah I mean
obviously you're not cuz the comics more
exposed everyone's just staring at me a
fail like oh this guy's bombed and I did
good that means I deserve
what he has and they're 100% right you
don't deserve anything you any time I
bomb anyone on that show deserves more
than me yeah they should be they should
just take over my life it's like
Highlander if they beat you with the mic
they get all your spoils and riches and
yeah they take over you they'll be the
the new Hans Kim or
whatever yeah going to be a lot of
people that are going to be the next
Hans Kim cuz I'm going to start Asian
people oh okay okay okay I'm going to
start bombing a lot because I think that
uh it's going to take me a while to
transition sure I well what do you
trying to transition into into doing the
open
mics and approaching a hostile crowd
sure um but I think that's that's going
to be totally worth it cuz I did open
mics for nine years sure so this is what
something that I'm used to it's
something that I know and I'm a little
out of practice right now but I'm uh I
can't wait to get back in the game
that's s okay
dude can't wait to have you hun you
can't be genuine for a moment I mean
have a heartfelt moment oh my God you
give me so much [__] about being a piece
of [__] dude I swear to God I think you
are like uh good at uh having like a a
track that you're on and it's very hard
to get you off that track once you're on
it
H okay we're talking about uh offstage
right not just in general yeah yeah no
yeah yeah yeah that's what I mean by
offstage yeah it's like personal my
actual personality or whatever yeah yeah
well both on stage and off stage okay
okay interesting what do you think about
uh people with
ADD um I think some of them are faking
it but you know you get along with them
is it hard to be with someone who's
jumpy well my Kinsey has
ADD ADHD and does it work out cuz you're
so calm and she's so excited so that's
in the middle most of the time well
you've heard of the like you been on Tik
Tok where it's avoidant attachment and
anxious attachment mhm that's that's me
and her so I'm avoiding attachment and
she's anxious so it's a it's a pretty
chaotic relationship a lot of the time
because of that yeah cuz it's like I
can't get my space enough and then she
needs to feel you know which which I was
actually thinking about this as a guy
you kind of have to be avoidant
attachment right you can't be an anxious
attachment guy because that's stalking
almost at that point you have too much
power sure yeah yeah yeah or like size
or fear you know yeah once you start
getting clingy it's like scary yeah it's
not fun or cute it's like dude get your
[__] together you're a man and then the
only way to do that as a man is just to
go in a corner by yourself and [__]
cry almost or just avoid it so they
don't see that [__] cuz you know like a
little girl coming to your house being
there people going to be like yeah
that's not good but you know what I mean
she needs to go but if it's like some 7
Foot eight dude coming to your house and
he's like oh the guy standing over the
tree yeah that's yeah that's a lot
that's that's going to be a lot for so
some personality types are uh ruled out
based on your body and your
sure you can't just see me pop out of
nowhere dude [__] like if you if you
took your brain and put it in like a
petite little cute thing yeah do you
think you would have developed a lot of
cute attributes or do you think that
your personality is pretty much the way
it is because it seems like it can't be
it it would have to change it would have
to change I would have been probably
slapped a lot more I've I've been
slapped a lot uh by dudes too uh because
because of my attitude but I think as a
or a or I don't know cuz ladies aren't
going to get hit but like or you know
what I mean like they shouldn't be
pushed around something like that yeah
there would have been a lot more scary
moments that I probably would have shut
my mouth faster because of the size
theze scary just thinking about how
you're constantly censoring yourself
sure and then you're like who am I as a
person yeah no it's uh it sucks for I
mean it sucks for men too but like yeah
it's uh it sucks for women in that in
that sense and I try to be mindful of it
cuz sometimes I'm like you know why
isn't
this lady talking to me I'm like well
that's weird you know I'm sure if she
talks to any guy they're like she's into
me and I'm like okay I'm not yeah
they're just avoidant they don't want to
like sure be worried about that yeah I
just try to change I just try to avoid
it all man I try to not talk to people
that don't want to talk to
me but sometimes it's like
are you sure they don't want to talk to
you or they just don't know how to you
know what I mean I'm not even saying you
in particular tell so yeah sometimes you
definitely can tell yeah yes they're
like I don't want to talk to you yeah
that usually is a good clue when they
say that I do not want to talk to you
yeah that's a it's
observant yeah I mean I think we're in a
time where there isn't as much wealth
trickling down so men are aren't as sexy
things are more desperate get more
desperate and so women are more closed
off yeah but I haven't had money in
forever and I still you know got
girlfriends and stuff I think it's just
you got to learn how to be a little more
emotional but it wouldn't be nice if
everything was working out and we didn't
have to like put in extra effort and any
extra effort would yield better results
yeah the extra effort is extra effort
not expected effort right so no I'm just
saying like it could be better like I
think like there's a like sex is very
sensitive like in a couple if you're
having marriage Mar like financial
problems you're not going to have as
much sex I think that's what's happening
now like what do most guys do they're
Uber drivers yeah or Postmates delivery
drivers so it's like they're not sexy
there's going to be less sex there's
less money you can't do as many cool
activities on a date yeah just stuck
staring at each
other yeah yeah yeah yeah no you're
right yeah I think it's that uh guys
need to start dating rich women stop
putting so much emphasis on looks and
[__] personality find you a provider
yeah well women love animals women love
animals they can Rescue all these little
[__] animals and [__] what lady
you know those ladies that have the dogs
that are like bigger than them you know
like the uh Great Dan yeah yeah where
it's like that date it's like that's the
lady you need to date a lady that wants
to own a lion or a [__] bear or a
wolf or whatever just be like a man
dingo to a woman sure sure I don't think
that's an animal that's
a
africanamerican that's a [__] is
David jool says [__] slave to
somebody yeah yeah yeah no well yeah
we're all slaves to something you know
what I mean yeah if the even if you get
to that top level where you're the top
guy you end up becoming like a to the
society or whatever like Elon Musk
doesn't really have to answer to it but
it really [__] up his day if he doesn't
at least have an ear to society you know
what I mean yeah he cares more yeah yeah
so it's like you're always beholden to
something you know it's just I think the
key is find someone you don't mind being
beholden to like that's the that's the
key to finding a better life for most
you know yeah cuz you could you know you
could have somebody that gives you
everything but if they're not like a
monster but just difficult to be around
like that's not that's a shitty life
yeah but you
know I mean this is a stretch here but
I'm sure there was like one slave back
in the day that was like I like I like
that guy that guy was that guy's always
been good to me the Masters yeah man one
just one sure he was like in the house
or something I don't [__] a slave
that had a great life yeah he was like
well that wasn't bad I was a slave but I
did everything I wanted I wish I wasn't
yeah I'm sure that's there and you know
maybe he still would have killed his
master or whatever but I'm sure he's
like you know I think you got to come to
peace with some of your [__] you know
cuz that's like with me you can't change
it if you're a slave in 1820 like what
are you going to do without luck start a
[__] cultural revolution well one did
obviously eventually it worked out but
sure sure not the slave I was thinking
of but uh he was more of an actor um but
yeah yeah yeah I'm sure he played a
slave to the government yeah yeah yeah I
don't think he played a
slave you don't know I mean I'm sure
they're doing blackface rampantly back
then I'm sure that was just like not an
actor of the caliber of John wilk's
Booth fair enough fair enough that guy
was well respected and look did well he
should be because of the second part or
the acting part both both okay good what
a what a what a good guy what
a what a masterful
performer yeah what's uh your opinions
on
things wow uh great question great
question um I try to have I I dude when
we were talking with David yesterday
here I I kind of like how David thinks
where it's like I want to be more like
that you don't care about politics the
little
it's I'm never I don't have power to do
anything and I don't want to March I'm
not marching like I just I'm just making
it to the next day and yeah and what are
you uh going to replace politics
with probably comedy comedy is where
it's at I or I replaced it religion with
comedy that's kind of what I did that's
more my church than anything so then
yeah and I think the
politics that do come to me is usually
done by who can say the funniest thing
bu it in a sense maybe that's like who
has the most
biting piece of material you know what I
mean cuz that's that's that's why uh
Democrats did so well I think in my
opinion was because of like John Stewart
and um uh whatever Co Bear yeah yeah Co
bear and all the even Trevor Noah uh I
but and I also think that's why the left
worked so hard in censoring comedy
because they realized how powerful it
was
because they they grew with John Stewart
and all those people and then you know
where it's
like they realized the power that it
that it was kind of so you just tried to
find the humor in politics as much as
possible [__] with politics for the most
if I ever got money and stuff yeah and I
have my opinions like on like subtler
more personal stuff but I'm not going to
be up there being like abortions wrong
or abortions right or like you know
unless I'm doing something you know like
you know the little funny abuse that I'm
doing on stage I'm not trying to make
huge points like that well what do you
think about people that are into
politics you think it's possible to be
into politics and just be a happy
person I mean happy person is a loaded
question um I would I would say
uh people that are into politics it's
just you know there's nothing I I I do
think we got to stop putting humor into
politics I mean stand up Comics fine but
like Donald Trump no and he's funny I'm
not I'm not denying that but but no but
he should stop doing like all of them
should stop doing jokes no comedy that's
cheating yes yeah it's like a
performance enhancing drug oh 100% and
it makes him makes him relevant and
stuff did I detect a smack Bob Dole but
disqualified but then as like Trump and
like cuz other politicians are trying
that trying to be being humorous not a
lot of them are good at it but they're
trying to be and then the that's why I
felt like the comedy was getting so
political it's like the roles reversed
where we were looking at politicians for
entertainment and we were looking at
comedians for guidance through through
the world where it's like it needs to be
the
politicians uh grouping us up and
keeping us together and then the
comedians are the ones that are like
we're the we're the [__] dredges of
of society like we're not supposed to be
up supposed to provide Cheap Thrills yes
in my opinion and there was and there
was and there was a place for that like
again I love John Stewart and Stephen
coar and stuff they were amazing but
it's like George Carla and Bill Hicks
sure yes well even that was
like it's it's really Steph colar and
John Stewart that I not blame but like
it made it more real cuz they weren't
just doing comedy they weren't putting
out specials they were doing like a new
show trying to influence things George
Carlin yeah he was doing the same thing
but that was like a special and stuff
and that was and that was cool as [__]
you know yeah granted it doesn't uh I
mean it keeps actually coming back to
reapply because I'll see like old George
you know people will clip his old clips
at a certain moment in time because
something's going off and then you'll be
like yeah that's that's still happening
right now and then you it AB own us yeah
we are owned a little bit me think you
feel owned you still feel like uh a
slave to society and stuff all a part of
it all right does not make me feel
better because you're doing pretty well
it's like thank you man I mean I do make
money independently now sure and people
come out to see me and I'm glad that you
know like I get to make money off of
like people choosing to pay me money not
like a corporation that does some random
[__] and profits and then gives me some
of it sure sure um but I am entertaining
people that are doing that from a
corporation doing whatever so I'm like
I'm not even like first level like I'm
like the least stable I'm the first to
go if there's anything that happens
you're you're some you're like you
you're not in the bottom of society but
you're in the bottom of of the machine
Society it's like a peacock's feather
like I'm like the little floofy little
thing on top like look what we can do
the little eye little
yeah it's like not very useful but it's
cool that I people want that job like
that's a desirable thing sure I mean I
have it and I don't really enjoy it all
the time yeah because of the negative
backlash but um wait what you get
Negative back people yeah I mean uh
overall it's like uh very luxurious or
cool thing to do but I don't I it's not
like I don't feel like that we're in a
[__] up society and all that yeah yeah
if you're if you're in a society like
that that's you're not going to feel
great even if you succeed yeah yeah yeah
what's the pressure feel like is it just
like do you just like stay up late like
racing thoughts or is it just like a
whole BL throughout the you know what
I'm saying like is it do you get what
I'm asking well like the pressure would
come in in terms of what to write or
what to think of next or what to joke
about next sure so that pressure feels
like uh constant like Dread of my head
yeah just like a weight like a axe above
my head not an axe above my head no that
sounds a lot it's just like a weight
just like having to think of things all
the time and being like every moment I'm
like is this a good thought is that a
good thought yeah that's a lot that is
lot yeah yeah it is good to relax and do
other things I can't I can imagine what
that's like and a you comedy well I'm
saying it's the same thing but yours is
like on steroids well obviously you know
what yeah yeah yeah like mine not that
strong no yeah I can turn it off pretty
easily I want to turn it on though yeah
um I want to be able to be in comedy
mode and mine every second of my life to
turn into bits no you can't do that you
can't do that that's wouldn't that be
better if you could just like every
second you come up with something new
and that's working out that's working
out 24 hours hours a day bodybuilders
don't do that you know what I mean they
have their rest days yeah but you you
need to live life you know saying train
twice the the better the more you train
the better you're going to get to a
degree and then I think it's Uh I that
degree can be trained you can work on
increasing that no I don't disagree with
that I yeah but I think all day cuz my
thing is I've been in comedy mode where
then it's like I'm burned out I don't
know what funny is more and stuff and
it's just like you got to relax and have
fun because if you're not having fun
that's not funny and then your
personality on stage is a lot like
drudgery yeah work yeah so not a person
that's having fun with their life no I
think people want to see you have
fun um thank you I I'm not one of those
people I'm not one of those people oh a
Rick Diaz fan no no no he's he's nice
but no yeah he's not nice to you certain
people yeah he unbs people that make him
bark oh really yeah yeah he shouldn't be
above that you know what I mean like I
get he should bark you don't have to
bark no you don't but you don't have to
unfollow someone also true because they
ask that's not that that's you maybe
they just didn't know even if they did
man uh I mean I'm not like I'm not
saying like I'm above it but it's like
I've been doing this for eight years I I
shouldn't be barking but bark yeah
[__] have to bark yeah I shouldn't
have to yeah I'm a decent enough comic I
should I mean for your own show that's
like that's a little different because
it's my show then then it's like owner
of the restaurant that's very handing
out free samples I would i' be like
buddy come over here you got to do you
want to hear a tiny
joke this place is 7eleven not
911 [__] [__] like that it's so funny
thatan people and like people from like
that the subcontinent of India like they
do a lot of the terrorism things it's
funny what from India jokes they do just
said 7 91 yes yes yes yes like I guess
kind of Cu you guys look similar but not
really CU India doesn't really do
terrorism to America they do it to each
other Pakistan and yes all that true
cashmir yeah yeah um I mean it's
probably some [__] but uh you know I
mean Muslims tend to be you know [__]
a little little out there Muslims get so
not all of them but angry so angry yeah
well they they're fighting with
everybody Christians Jews Hindus I don't
know Buddhists probably I'm sure they're
fighting with scientologists but
scientologists are probably like China
whatever religion China is the wigger
the Wego or whatever wigers yeah yeah
yeah I forget what got an indigenous
population of wiggers in China yeah it's
listening to Limp Biscuit probably yeah
is that wigger stuff [__] Lim biscuit
you don't think so I was think I guess
that's more white just white yeah wi
would be like memem or sure yes black
people like yeah music and from the 90s
or 2000s because wiggers aren't really a
thing anymore no NE they're I wonder
what they evolved into because you know
like Chad Hanks Chad Hanks sure okay
yeah yeah the Jamaican post Malone
[__]
yeah post Malone it's post after all the
Malon he's from Dallas nice just saying
all the big rappers from Dallas are
white it's vanilla Vanilla Ice and post
Malone yeah which is sad because Dallas
has a a pretty good rap scene
interesting Houston
too do you think black Comics are more
talented than no the other Comics
definitely not subhuman no no uh they're
different it's weird how people try to
act like race isn't a thing but it's
like it's a [__] thing I think black
people that are good at
comedy uh just know it faster and do it
more and people because there's some bad
black Comics
sure yeah and a lot of them drop off
maybe that's just is what happens faster
but there are some amazing black Comics
100% no yeah yeah yeah talking about I
think on average there's more great
black I think cuz they also have a
culture of it they grew up with Eddie
Murphy Richard PRI there are black CL I
didn't have an Asian no Asian Murphy no
Indian Eddie Murphy Russell Peter's a
bit but that's not you know that's way
later yeah yeah but I just think black
Comics are some of the best and like I
love the culture that they have like Def
Jam and all that that's yeah the Apollo
I mean black people are like the black
people in NBA it's I think it's the same
in comedy it's black it's like it's like
yeah there's just like one Asian guy and
[__] I don't think there's an Indian
guy in basketball yet so you one day one
day that's going to happen we'll see I
don't you guys aren't as short no that's
so I mean overall it's you know like you
know I think it's it's a statistic thing
once you get to a billion it starts L
you know what I mean like yeah there's
of course tall Indian people tall Asian
people but yeah yeah just read that much
just monoculture kind of [__] yeah they
get better and
better or worse one way to say that yeah
that's one way yeah yeah I don't know if
better yeah so uh what do you think what
do you want to do now it's
7 um I'm fine with whatever we got you
got your
show
yeah and yeah and I was going to hit up
the mics and stuff down
there that was pretty much it
I don't think we have to leave now you
want to do 30 more minutes yeah you got
you got like it's a live chat what are
the [__] comments at all you ever
read those yeah great job you're doing
great who's that
too just
us
H
uh do you talk to your fans a
lot
um not really yeah I wouldn't either
yeah yeah people are like talking about
the Battle oh nice they're like why
don't you prepare more I was like I
thought those were good jokes I'm sorry
yeah yeah yeah well so that's why I
don't even like roast battles either
because like sometimes I'll have like 10
jokes I'm like I don't know which and
then the ones I think work cuz there's
no open mic to it you know what I'm
saying you battles yeah you were
figuring it out I was doing those bits
do you heard me do those bits in
h the white uh the toilet seat
one yeah yes yes I do remember doing
that it was working it wor it worked
that night you think so New Year's Eve
didn't work online nice yeah they're
really angry I think they're a little
overreacting but I I think they see
blood wasn't happy with that set
either I was just sort of like going I
couldn't really watch cuz they threw me
in the back
by this and I like it was just they kind
of ruined the show for me in that sense
yeah well I feel like
uh the uh the bit didn't go over the way
that I wanted it to and I didn't feel it
feel it in the in the arena like I
didn't feel like saying that joke I
didn't feel like I delivered it well did
you want to change it to something or
were you just like I wanted to change it
to something but I literally didn't have
any other jokes that I could do hm like
I was trapped in a corner and I wish I
could have called an audible but uh yeah
those are the jokes that I [__] chose
two months before I was like this will
be good take this home and pack it in
your bag and take it to you on New
Year's Eve and then I'm like doing this
joke that I thought would be funny two
months ago and I'm like well the best I
can do is just do it the best I can yeah
yeah yeah I just [__] I mean you that
pressure is even weirder cuz it's like
you pretty much have everything to lose
and nothing to gain you know what I mean
if you win it's not like you get money
or you just got to stay on the show you
I won and look what happened yeah true I
almost wish be lost yeah yeah yeah it's
like why do you cheer for me and then
[__] all over me if you don't that's the
crap that's that's society though yeah
yeah that's make up your mind yeah yeah
yeah if you wanted me to lose you you
should have let me lose don't cheer for
me bring me up just so you can [__]
[__] all over me I boo I booed for you
dude thank you man at least you're
honest the true signal no I'm no I'm
really not I'm not I didn't do anything
I was just surprised I was back there
that was that was more my cuz they were
doing the $10,000 thing I they didn't
tell us that you were they were just
like come on come on yeah they're like
stay here sit here do not move and then
I mean they were like you can move but
they're like if you they're going to Har
harass you I I heard no I heard but then
it's like I couldn't I couldn't see any
reactions or anything like but you heard
yes yes yeah and no I thought it was to
be honest pretty even like the laughs of
of who won yeah I mean I don't remember
the I don't even remember Rick
Diaz's uh jokes or anything like that
you just remember the reaction and
that's usually how I operate for the
most part I think the internet is sort
of uh cruel and unusual gone off the
deep end sure sure sure you know that's
also because of the place you play in
though you know what I mean I think
they're sick of me I think that I have
been uh not doing the best on kill Tony
recently so all that pent up rage I
think it came out why do you think that
is um I think it's because I had a white
girlfriend sure spoiled you was just
taking up so much time okay and it's not
like her fault she likes me she wants to
hang out with me I just needed to set
strict stricter boundaries and I just
couldn't I get that um yeah I mean I
think that took a lot of time away those
white women will take all the boundaries
soon yeah they don't care about any
boundaries to flag anywhere they want
they want to be like attached to you a
little bit yeah yeah I I mean they want
the full boyfriend experience they're
not signing up for a half part-time
boyfriend if they're going to have a
boyfriend I think that's the full
boyfriend experience is not being there
sometimes yeah you're supposed to have
your own lives I mean I'm not speaking
on your relationship but on like mine I
think we had a lot of time apart that's
good no then that is unfortunately you
know but okay I don't know I feel like
if you have a best friend you're not
like oh I don't want to hang out with
you I no but like a guy if you have
someone you like hanging out with why
would you be like no I think some
relationships are like oh you're my
girlfriend and you provide this very
specific role sure and then hanging out
I don't need that role fulfilled it
actually gets in the way of what I want
to do sure with the boys yeah um but I
think ideally you'd be able to
incorporate everyone in your life
together and you know meld all their
energy yeah key words ideally humans are
complicated puzzle pieces that I know
what humans are yeah I know but like
yeah I would love for my good guy
friends to hang out with my good
girlfriend but then sometimes they don't
get along or whatever and then it's just
like you know it's uh you only get you
know back back to being like a happy
person I don't think there's a happy
person I just think there's like
fleeting moments of happiness you know
yeah I did the kill Tony thing I didn't
feel that happy afterwards I didn't feel
bad but I just kind of felt a little
empty where I was like you're like I did
it yeah kind of and it was such a weird
one to do had a great set I'm not I'm
not good with the compliments but yeah
people I also got booed the I've been
telling people I've I've gotten more
booze than they've gotten laughs now
because of that of all the people that
were me yeah yeah yeah I felt like there
was a lot of setup that you didn't need
for that one but for the guitar no for
the uh joke are you talking about the
Indian one yeah uh yeah probably but I
had dude I was not prepared for that the
kilon I had I just was going there cuz
you know Kenzie was going there I was
like I'll just watch the show or
whatever and yeah called yeah it was
100% survival mode when I was up on
stage dude I was kind of seeing double
vision like my adrenaline was pumping
through the roof where I was just like
and then did you look out at the crowd I
had to tell myself three four times to
be like scan the do do the thing like
don't just look at the ground or
whatever like make sure you're making
eye contact with these people while I'm
doing it it was 100% survival mode so
did you like make eye contact and take a
survey of the crowd and try to like make
it a normal room yes no 100% it was all
the stuff that I've trained for in the
past whatever you know not train but you
know all the gigs I've done in the past
eight years that it was the moment it's
insane to put somebody up for their
first time in front of I'm not saying me
but like some of those comics where it
was just like whoa there's nothing good
come out either they get booed the [__]
out of and then they're like holy [__]
or they kill which is great but then
they have to go back then they have to
go back to like bar or you know maybe
they decide to start doing open mic
comedy and then it's like bro like
you're going to have a lot of these two
people in a room that you sit in for
three hours to do yeah comp write and
then you write all your bits for Arenas
and it doesn't yeah yeah yeah yeah you
go up there like what's
up yeah are you guys really ready not
yeah yeah instead it's just you know the
buddy you came with and some person that
doesn't want to leave the bar you know
like yeah I mean uh so you get called up
do they come pick you up out out of the
crowd and then they well uh down Tony
Tony said my name wrong or at least the
last name wrong where I was like I don't
think that's me and then I had then I
was like two I was like no that that has
to be so he didn't even pre-pull it he
just was like pulling it live and then
you to go down there did you
run moved I walked fast that's a big
mistake is you should never run cuz then
you get to the stage and out of breath
that's what happened to me my first time
kill Tony yeah yeah yeah I was like oh
no I don't want to make everyone wait
but you got to make them you got to make
them wait no they made me wait when I
got up there so like I had to sit in the
back and some guy was using some lights
to like hold me back and then yeah
nobody told me anything dude it was
[__] chaos yeah and I can I you know
what I think I can handle or I don't
know I think I could handle an 8,000
crowd room if I have some [__] heads
up like this is going from like sitting
in my seat being like oh this is an
interesting show or actually I was
really cool to see Shane and Matt there
and being like Oh that's [__] awesome
to being like oh crap I got to [__]
do standup and I'm like I God yeah yeah
that's the crazy thing about the show
it's not you're not just like getting
ready for your big moment you're just
pulled out and then it's like what yes
yes where I was just like holy [__] dude
you want to hear a funny story about
that though uh so the so my friend was
with me uh I'm going to say his name
Tony compon and um he supposedly got
pulled after me so he was supposed to go
up after me cuz they were looking for
him they they pulled it and they're like
oh here you go and [__] he wasn't
there so then that guy with the broken
dick ended up going up so if Tony was
there his son right his son went up then
yes yes so that guy wouldn't have gone
up so that means the $10,000 wouldn't
have gone to him because he would have
never been on stage so it probably would
have been me Tony's a pretty good comic
or that first guy that would have would
have won the $10,000 so that's two out
of three well who knows so I've been
blaming ility Works know I know I just
want I like blaming Tony I say Tony owes
me $10,000 that's pretty much could have
made the show shittier he does do that
too I mean I'm not saying he he would
have made a sh I'm saying like that guy
not being there yeah yeah his broken
dick you know [__] yeah yeah I should
have shown my dick dude I just I didn't
know that was an option yeah yeah yeah I
thought were a Duo cuz they came off off
stage and they were together and I was
like I didn't cuz again I couldn't watch
the show really like I heard stuff but
it's like it's not the same and well
it'll come out in a couple weeks now I'm
already I don't know you're not excited
I don't know I mean the set went well
and everything interview went pretty
well and then the booing at the end with
the guitar and stuff I was like yeah
that that's that's actually more what
I'm looking forward to to seeing how
that looks on video me getting booed by
that many people yeah you have like a
strange fascination with uh I don't mind
getting boot I I I I mean I didn't fully
enjoy that because it was unexpected but
a couple booze is not I'm not sensitive
about that yeah
yeah um yeah I mean I thought thought it
was a crazy experience it is that was
it's such a great show for an arena cuz
you got so many crazy things happening
true people coming out Mr Beast [__]
competitions true no that was like a
rock Dr Phil he killed I had to follow
him that's the guy I had to [__]
follow to and he [__] Adam Ray
[__] destroyed and I was like gez
yeah yeah and the in a normal standup
show it's like um they're already so
excited you just make them yeah slightly
more excited yeah yeah but uh yeah
standup is amazing in arenas too I think
uh it was different thing I I was a
little like like I'm not against doing
it but I like a comedy club I like tops
three five 600 people not that I've done
that so it's only been like 3 to 400 to
the next jump is that Arena so I haven't
had anything in between but I like being
able to like interact with the front
crowd where the back crowd can still
listen you you know what I'm saying at a
certain point it's like and I'm fine
with like repeating what they say and I
know how to do that with crowd work and
stuff but it's like I like that
intimacy of it's more real um you're in
a room people it's not like you're
elevated and you're shiny and glittering
and people just want to hear me say my
stuff and then yeah move on kind of deal
yeah I I really like the interaction in
standup that's that's a big part of my
stuff at least and it saves a lot of my
jokes half the time too so maybe that's
that's part of the reason because if a
joke fails I can always go to the
audience and manage to save most of the
time yeah you can talk to them you can
be like a human but if you start talking
in like a giant place they'll be like
why are you talking to this
specific it doesn't feel like you're
connected to that person no no no no so
it's hard to feel engaged yeah what's uh
what are your thoughts on the the whole
comedy Mothership comedy
Club [__] hole right I think we can
agree on that yeah worst thing that's
ever happened to Comedy I I uh Joe
Rogan's been touching me sexually every
time I'm there no I think it's uh great
great place I think the crowds there are
so good that it spoils me for every
other crowd I did the open mic on Sunday
and yeah all dude the open mic's amazing
I can't even imagine what like the creu
show is like cuz I the the lights are
dimmed right yeah yeah which changes
things it's funny how that that can
change the environment just like that
but because when people know that you're
looking at their face yeah they are more
like yeah scared yeah yeah I like them
scared it's good it's good when they're
scared dude [__] yeah like scaring
them too yeah showing my start showing
my dick man I'm gonna start showing my
dick I think that's that's the missing
ingredient such a go-to it's like
whenever anything is happening I'm just
like I could just do that right now like
but you don't want to do that no unless
you got you don't want to go go to that
all the time no no no you can't be the
Bert crer of [__] dick
showing the ber crer of dicks yeah
yeah yeah cuz it's like so do you think
you're doing good funny because it's
threaten do feeling good right now are
you just like in
a uh like bit of a weird spot or you
just like go back to basics
or um I mean do you have feelings I
think that if you're going to ask me
about my
feelings um I don't know it's just like
some people are open to talking about
their feelings fair and I think like
they they don't mind telling
people um but I guess I'm more
introverted and I don't like that's yeah
that's I mean hopefully you could sense
how I feel just by talking to me we
don't have to like make it explicit yeah
yeah well you're uh a hard you're a hard
person to read well I think you're more
emotionally uh outgoing than me true
yeah that means I think I should be able
to read you better cuz I I feel good I
feel good when I'm like doing like stuff
like this cuz I feel like this is
helpful and practice sure I feel good
when I'm doing sets that's I mean that's
you're pretty much the same as me then
that's about night wasn't my best night
but uh I've had some sets recently that
made me feel better like oh they don't
know what they're talking about they're
idiots sure
online ID doing real sets really helps
with that that's why I love standup
comedy it's like it doesn't matter
what's happening online when you're in a
room that's all that matters in front of
audience they don't want you to fail
they don't want to have a bad time they
want to see good comedy even if they
hate your guts true cuz it's just like a
better use of their time yeah yeah and
they've seen you know people not do good
comedy they don't want that again yeah
they're like oh please if if you could
do
well I will give you the laughs that you
need yeah so I I don't ever feel like
they're biased against me and I feel
like pretty confident so the stand Up's
kind of saving you a little bit right
uh yeah I mean I mean that's the only
thing helping me also got me into this
mess yes true to D I mean it's double
sword right and it's like you got to
keep growing for the most part thing I'm
a comic like you can't take that away
from I might not be your favorite comic
and I might not do well but I um I think
I do well in certain situations and
certain settings and one
minute uh I don't think uh my autism is
very endearing in a minute I think maybe
you have to work up to it oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah I also think like there's
a lot of holes in my game that are
exposed in that minute like I'm
unlikable I come off as cocky or
whatever sometimes yeah I don't think
you're unlikable though well that's like
a harsh thing way to put it but it's
like at some points everyone is
unlikable sure okay I get what you're
saying yeah yeah yeah no I feel
unlikable a lot too so when you say
things like where I'm like oh that I
mean that is also true where it's like I
feel like I have to remind myself that
sometimes going up on stage and and in a
sense that's why sometimes the open mics
are bad because it's like you just
assume nobody wants to listen and then
you go to real shows and everybody's
like what [__] we're on your side we're
listening stop yelling at her tell us
what you want to say yeah it's like so
many of open mics are just trying to get
their attention dude anything so then it
becomes shock value [__] a lot and
whatnot or little tricks or
hey you hear about this yeah
yeah
yeah I think comedy is great you know
there's so many different ways to do it
you can never just figure it out yeah
that's why I'm not a big proponent about
comedy classes I really I hate those I
don't like people telling you what to do
uh no it's more the money aspect of it
please do your comedy classes but do it
for free or at least a [__] at a
community college yeah yeah do it for
the community yeah I that I can respect
but then instead I see these classes and
they like $500 for like eight weeks and
it's just like okay that's too long of a
class and too much of a class you know
what a comic class I think should be it
should honestly be obviously a really
good comic just going to open mics with
brand new Comics like just going to like
eight weeks of open mics with them and
then not telling them to do but being
like you could take that joke here you
could take that joke here you know what
I mean like it's so tricky to do that
though cuz you don't want to just be
like dude you need to stop saying that
put that up front put that in the back
because then you're just doing it for
them yes I think the tricky thing is
like to give them one piece of advice
that's going to change everything else
yeah yeah well I just mean like
suggestions not even telling I wasn't
yeah I wasn't like oh you're yeah
example I'm not saying like right the
you need to you need to the stool right
here to do I I wouldn't even want to
start cuz then it's like what if you
ruin this person like I mean some of
them aren't going to be funny no matter
what so that's the weird part where then
you're like so what do you think funny
is uh on stage is it like an awareness
of the room and to to your voice mean
you can write like someone can do
someone else's act and be funny but then
to keep going with it and being able to
create with it I think it just you have
to have a bit of a
uh an odity to what mainstream Society
likes like I think you have to be an
outsider and then that Outsider shines
out of you because it resonates with
mainstream Society for whatever reason
that it does so so I'm not saying like
you have to be image but Society to them
say again they reflect part of Mainline
Society to them uh yeah yeah yeah same
reason why people like seeing animals
act like humans you know what I'm saying
that's almost what it is it's seeing an
outsider that's not in acting like them
and you're like that guy's as human as
us I think uh it could be like a guy or
a girl going up on stage and being like
hey look what I
noticed and uh being like so we're
saying like Jerry Seinfield there I'm
I'm assuming he kind of was an outsider
originally and then yeah he just blew up
blew the [__] up too fast well I feel
like it's a person being like
uh in in a room of
people um changing the energy
to be one of uh you know bringing them
to a place where they're like okay now
I'm at walking my dog in front of my
apartment and this guy comes up and then
he says um something crazy and it's like
uh I guess being able to bring them to a
scenario and then
do uh portray an action that uh you know
like shocks them or like is unexpected
or surprise is informative yeah yeah I I
think that guy thinking like that though
is an outsider in a sense I still like
because I'm not saying you have to be
damaged but if you're on the outside of
society you tend to get damaged so then
it's like yeah to usually damage people
at end of the day but if you're just on
the outside the fringes of society I
think that's where the comedy comes from
I don't I think it's taking the energy
of the room and your energy and melding
it together to create uh a different
perspective finding machine mhm so
you're using and you think that like a
regular joeo could do
that um in a sense I think it helps if
you're aware of the energy in the room
and some people are more aware of it
than not sure sure I would say that's a
skill yeah right there are some things
you could say that will automatically
get to laugh yeah like yeah yeah like
just onliners some people can just but
then the guys that write these onliners
tend to be isolated [__] that
are like not talking anybody they have
to manage their emotion to not come off
wrong like true if you say one liner
angry it's going to get a different
reaction still controlling the energy
the room with their energy their voice a
lot of those Outsiders that are funny
still won't be able to make it because
of personal problems or whatever which
though I think happen because they're on
the outside of society they don't really
have that comfort and safety that you
have well who's on the inside of society
doesn't everyone feel like they're on
the outside no no no everyone has a
different perspective on the thing true
I yeah and everybody can feel like an
outsider I'm not I'm not saying that but
you know people that aren't invited to
parties or people that aren't included
in the group that's that's so you're
saying Matt re can't be funny because
he's invited to
parties I mean his b is that like he's
got some jokes he's got some jokes and
his jokes that he got canceled for bull
are [__] like it wasn't that bad of
a joke but I get it turning on your bass
like that but yeah yeah he's not you
know this is what I'm saying it's like
you can be you can say words in a
scripted way that you know I Matt Matt R
is
charming like he is funny but he's more
Charming than funny I think which is
which is fine I'm not hating on him at
all I like I kind of it's I'm interested
to see what happens with him now that he
did this like I'm fascinated with this
dude where it's like you had your [__]
for you let's you wanted to be a
comedian let's let's [__] I mean you
you technically are but I'm saying like
let's find out man let's see what you
can do now that you're on the you know
[__] list for at least women you know
and I don't think guys I don't think he
got the support from guys that he was
expecting from doing that so it so it
kind of like he lost his fan base and
didn't really
gain men's fan base or whatever yeah I
don't know if it was that calculated but
I'm sure somewhere in the back of his
mind that that was his first joke I'm
sure that wasn't I'm sure he was like
this is an easy dark joke it's not that
offensive I mean some people disagree
and then I heard I saw a special and I
was like all right that he got his
laughs I think he was just trying to set
the tone to be like hey you know granted
his [__] ending was just so corny I
no and that's fair that's fair his
ending was corny in the sense he's like
oh you guys just think I'm a crowdwork
comic and then he drops the mic and I'm
like yeah that's not he's trying to
reinvent he like not happy with yeah
what got him success yeah yeah he's
which I relate to that must be hard to
just be like oh I gotta yeah bang women
all the time what a [__] more than
this oh what a hard I want to bang dudes
too yeah yeah D I get it I totally get
it I totally get wanting to bang dudes
he's he's climbed the mountain that is
women and now is trying to go into the
[__] Canyon that is men's but yes I
think uh he is great I think that just
cuz you're invited to parties doesn't
mean you can't funny I think it's harder
to be funny because you don't have to be
funny if you're already satisfied and
happy you just have to enjoy but when
you are on the outside I think it's
easier to be funny because you need it
because you can't produce you know
wealth or yeah yeah parties you just
have to do it with your little
brain okay take offense to that pretty B
it's a pretty big brain just the fact
that you have to do it with a brain at
all is sad you should be able to do it
with like a forklift and a motorboat
sure no but that's what happens the
comics that make it closer and closer
into society get those resources and
that money that then they can then they
turn soft some of them do some of them
triple down yeah some of them are able
to get through I mean it's it's uh it's
[__] like seats funny is so weird of
a thing to pursue yes it's fleeting
doesn't exist also why I like it cuz
there's no meaning it depends on the
room yeah 100% And the audience it's a
crazy thing to like stake your career
and life on like this the fact that
we've both have murdered where it's just
like [__] chaos is amazing it it
shouldn't make any sense that you know
that that shouldn't be happening that's
I like listen to recordings I'm like oh
the audience is just being nice to me
but that's like a part of Comedy is like
getting the audience to be nice to you
you might be you might be overthinking
that a little bit though yeah I don't
think they're being I'm sure if they
didn't want to laugh they
well they are being nice to me but
what's wrong with being nice to me no
also true but yeah yeah yeah but it is
sort of like you want to earn it you
don't want to just like I get what
you're saying no no I get what you're
saying on that yeah cuz if they laugh at
a really stupid joke of mine I'll
sometimes turn on the audience and be
like you guys are idiots like you
shouldn't have given me that much and
that sometimes worked in my favor and
sometimes it's backlash but then they're
like all right we're not going to laugh
at your jokes as much and I'm like I
[__] up you done that thing where
there's a person that's laughing weird
and then you point it out and that ruins
the yeah sure I did that that show got
to be you go to there's a line on that
yeah you can point it out but then yeah
yeah and then they just stop laughing
after that they're just like
uncomfortable like [__] dude yeah yeah
it's like I didn't have to point it out
but it is so distracting when they're
doing that and they have to know cuz
everyone is silent and they're like
making weird noises yeah it's like
you're you're being weird like now you
make you're making me call you out yeah
maybe they can't help it maybe that's
the
yeah yeah yeah but sometimes they're
just laughing at premises and [__] just
because they think it's funny like oh
look this guy's still up there talking
about butts and poop and [__] and they
can't help it but laugh but it's like it
kind of [__] it because everyone's like
whoa that guy doesn't make it look
cool W but it's a but it's fun though
yeah it's not cool but it's
like that guy enjoying that guy's
enjoying himself that's the peak of
comedy is some cackling hyena that's
what we're all trying to get to in a
comedy some snorting and whatnot yeah
yeah yeah we all don't want to admit it
no we don't want to be like I want to be
like that guy we're like
sophisticated yeah cuz I don't laugh I
don't laugh a lot in comedy clubs L
times yeah well you're a comedian I know
but I want to go back to why I got into
this yeah yeah yeah I laugh among to
comedy clubs before I started comedy me
neither I watched a lot I was just like
yeah I want to do the TV thing I want to
be you never watched you never watched
no I did I'm saying that's what I wanted
to do I wanted to be famous more than I
wanted to talk to people in a room and
then I'm you can still do that doing
that I'm like oh [__] this is what I
actually love oh nice that's funny yeah
because I was like always like in class
that's the format yeah person talking
and students in church I went to church
pastor and students so I'm used to that
format yeah and I want to go up there
and be like hey you want to be the
priest butthole to have that power and
to use it for nothing I think is like so
funny that's what you should use power
for nothing yeah AG too much power to
have uh yeah yeah yeah and if you're
like hey I'm going to use this to like
make fun of myself then it's like okay
using the power yeah yeah yeah yeah I
still like making fun other people but
it's it's
uh yeah it's uh like I don't want to be
one of those guys who got to use the
power respectfully but then it's like
you know for me I'm I'm trying to a
little bit but at the end of the day
this is meaningless so it's like don't
don't give me don't give me too much
grief if I [__] up because you know this
is just in the moment and that's it
which is why I love it trying to make
you laugh
yeah usually pretty bad with that but
you know yeah but it's like why do I
want you to laugh cuz it's good for my
career it's not like totally see that is
where it gets weird once the business
side kicks in which that's been
happening over the past like two three
years where it's like okay like I Gotta
Be You know the the the charm of just
being like I can make a group of
strangers laugh is kind of worn off
where it's like I need I need stability
I need [__] you're like yeah great human
happiness what's next yes you got
anything else kid yeah yeah want to buy
some merch
no um yeah I mean
I think
uh I think comedy is such a weird art
form and it's pretty new it's not like
music no yeah it's like you're just
trying to pursue this reaction yeah it's
like 1920s kind of [__] yeah and to be
the best at it you got to like kind of
go away from what you think the audience
wants and yourself yeah yeah you got to
be on you were saying this yesterday uh
Cutting Edge of what's the next thing
cuz things
cuz the second one per one comic says it
it's got like a six-month shelf life
where then every other comic follows
through with doing the same kind of
thing in a different way and then just
becomes kind of hacky
yeah I mean I don't mind a little hack
but yeah yeah too too much hat it's like
sugar to me you don't want only sugar
you yeah you want unique perspectives
you don't want to hear but I'm saying
unique perspectives with a little bit of
hack it's not that not you know hack I
think has a different level yeah some
people are diabetic that's that's all I
mean well let's call it a night yeah
yeah thank you H after the shows yeah
sure man um hey follow me on Instagram
uh the fake she do it that's it you're
gonna regret it oh really I could use
the fall you can boo I'm probably going
to regret that uh you can [__] Boo
and do whatever you want don't follow
Shiva at the fake Shiva Ari report
report uh the fake Shiva
Instagram follow Shiva very funny comic
now lives in Austin killed it at hyenas
yep got to kill Tony not for not for
theed but for GU I can play guitar by
the way but you were playing power cords
and Matt mcer was like doing a solo I
but I set that up for Matt so in a sense
I did that I just want to put that he
would have never touched the guitar if I
didn't touch the guitar when you people
when you say I know how to play guitar
people don't want to hear like you know
I do smells
like okay okay you knows and Smells Like
Teen Spirit they want to hear s like yes
yeah yeah yeah well I also forgot I
don't know if I can play in front of
8,000 people I know I can play Guitar
Play like guitar solo yes you should
have done that I just I was on the spot
and I just yeah I was just trying to
figure it out and also uh the thing was
too high on me and I didn't want to [__]
with it and I was just I was trying to
make do with what he didn't even want to
give you the guitar
he should have he shouldn't have he
should he should have given it to Matt
immediately and then yeah what what are
you well you brought it up right he
asked my spe I didn't have anything it
was either that or heroin and I was like
that's that's such a weird thing to
that's not a special you could have ,000
it is a special skill what do you think
they would give me the 10 they would be
like we can't give him the $10,000 he's
going to spend it on heroin tonight dude
like good
night man yeah yeah yeah that was fun
that was uh better than that mic that
was that's for
sure had came up with any
bits what what do you
mean uh yeah mainly the kill Tony stuff
I've been working on the [__] that the
podcast oh did I yeah did you cuz that's
what I use podcast for should like um no
not this time
no it was a lot of philosophy so it was
like